[Applaudissements]
fraction de seconde
salé où vous êtes dit non et plein
finaux fait non c'est pas du tout ce que
tu crois mais vous quel est votre
technique alors du coup je veux pas
prendre ce risque
when a man donc du coup je m'approche
pas doucement jusque là évidemment je
vous laisse trop le temps de dire non
non je fais la cave où j'allais à la
sauvage jeu la technique du cobra
lassitude à tous le goût des livres un
peu bush a que comme ça et que ça lui en
fait lui a fait du mal je voulais après
je pêche aux canards
non mais à ce qu est ce qu au point de
faire sans embrasser jusqu'au bout
valérie vidal et bon d'accord vous la
ramenez chez elle
varela juste avant alors valérie vous la
ramenez chez elle vous êtes en bas de
chez elle
d'accord alors que tu lui dis bombe à
ahnif la cucina j'ai passé une très
bonne soirée j'aimerais bien te voir
demain
et puis est ce que je t'ai dit
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]